[Music]
well let me welcome you to year for this
quarterly talk series where we look at
philosophers in the middle of their
historical situation I always try to
pick people who both were shaped by
their their history and who made some
contributions and in some respects
perhaps altered history in some
important ways so it's it's a winter
right so we kick off with an ancient
philosopher we've done Plato we've done
Aristotle we did Cicero last year so
it's time for a stoic so I thought
Epictetus would probably be the most
interesting person to do although you
know then when I started doing you know
putting it all together and thinking
about what do we actually know about the
guy we don't actually know quite as much
about him as we do say Seneca or Marcus
Aurelius with some of these other stoic
so maybe it was not the best decision we
know a lot about what he thought but we
don't know that much about his his
biography but we do know that he lived
in very interesting times and that he
was caught up in some of the both
intellectual and political events of his
own time he tried to stay out of it as
much as possible or didn't have much of
an opportunity in some cases to to do
much of anything politically although he
wasn't actually quite close to power if
you think about it one of the things
we'll talk about he was a slave so that
sounds like a bad thing but he was a
slave to somebody else who was a freed
slave who then was the secretary to Nero
so it would be sort of like being the
terribly treated servant of I don't know
somebody who's taking care of the
president or something along those lines
perhaps maybe somebody more like taking
care of the you know Russian Prime
Minister because our president doesn't
have quite the same authoritarian power
as maybe you know the current Prime
Minister does so you know he was
actually quite close to power but he
didn't seem to make any impact on
it could because he was so young at the
time so what I do in this is talk about
the history of the Philosopher's life
their biography the historical situation
that they were in what it meant for for
them in part and and what it could mean
for us and when it comes to the Roman
Empire and stoicism there's actually you
know there have been changes in the way
that we look at it a lot of people
thought of stoicism for a long time as a
sort of let's call it a cop-out a
philosophy of pessimism and withdrawal
from a screwed up time where everything
was breaking down and going badly but
that actually wasn't quite true and
there's a lot more to stoicism certainly
the way that Epictetus teaches it and we
have some people here from the stoic
fellowship so a lot a lot of discussion
I think about about that so I want to
talk about that and then I thought we
could talk about
Epictetus own contributions to stoic
philosophy and his influence beyond his
time he's he's one of the three late
Roman Stoics who we have writings from
actually we do have a few others we have
some bits and pieces of some and we
actually have a few other texts but he's
one of the most important ones and and
his thought you know pops up in the
Renaissance there were Christians
earlier on who are copying out his text
so we'll talk about that and then we can
talk about you know what his thought
means for the present but let's jump
back into ancient Rome so you know the
around the time that epictetus is born
he's really a an immigrant in many
respects to Rome we think of Rome is
like you know centered in the city of
Rome and then radiating outward in terms
of the imperial power through Italy and
you know the rest of Europe and the
Mediterranean and though that's
certainly true although the eastern
Mediterranean was starting to become
more and more important in part because
there were more people there and
there were the Romans had spread and
taken over a lot of territory that
conquered all of Alexander the Great's
successor kingdoms they had beaten
Pyrus of Epirus who had you know
pretensions at one time to be another
alexander long before that they beaten
the Carthaginians to the to the south
and to the west of them and they were
sparring quite often with other cultures
like the Persian Empire or you know they
penetrated as far down into Egypt as you
could go so Roman power was was you know
encompassing this very wide matrix and
some of the people in that area were
speaking Latin in the West many of them
were Greek speakers and Greek culture
and Roman culture were starting to
interfere some of that was led by people
long before epictetus is time like like
Cicero the Roman philosopher and States
person who'd gone to the for the East
they would often send young know Noble
or equestrian
men out there to get them ready for
power and then have him study with with
philosophers before they started taking
on real jobs and going through what was
called the cursus honorum
and Cicero was a you know very
appreciative of Greek culture but he
wanted to translate it into laughs and
then you know we have somebody else
who's you know around the same era
Plutarch you know who we know from
Plutarch's lives Plutarch also wrote a
lot of other stuff as well
and even the lives the idea is you know
parallel lives
you got a Roman you got a Greek and why
is he doing this comparison he's trying
to bring the cultures together and this
was something that it you know been
carried out in large part by Epictetus
times so he's he's born in this place
here appleís in Phrygia so a part of
Asia Minor and you know a little bit
before he's born Seneca comes to Rome
begins tutoring Nero
you know you've got the dynastic things
that's going on and Epictetus quite
early on he's acquired as a slave by @ba
Frobenius we don't actually know what
epictetus his real name was
Epictetus just means piece of property
and he kind of stuck with that I guess
the way that we have nicknames and then
again you know there's plenty of other
famous people Plato we do know what what
his name was but I can't remember off
the bat Plato's was a nickname that was
given to him probably because of being
quite broad and we have a lot of people
like that you know nowadays we have
celebrities who go by their monikers
right anyway at Beaufort he just takes
Epictetus with him to to Rome and at
Bath wordiness is is somebody who's
close to Nero he's he's essentially his
secretary
so he's intimately involved with his
affairs eventually you know well I've
got a thing wrong here Nero you know
becomes more and more despotic
eventually has his mother killed Seneca
doesn't have a grip Pina killed
Nero does and you notice that in these
three columns there's not a lot for
epictetus because we know of some things
that he did but we don't know when he
did them for the most part but we do
know about all this other stuff somebody
who's really important for epic G this
is another Roman philosopher was Sonia
srutis he's a stoic philosopher we have
some of his work we have some lectures
that he gave we have some fragments of
his stuff but we don't have a lot from
him
and at bar adidas let's let epictetus
study with with Missoni Rufus but you
notice he's gone quite a bit at the time
there's this constant back and forth of
philosophers having to go into exile
now why would they why would they go
into exile I mean sometimes exiles are
self-imposed in which case
sometimes we call it an exile sometimes
we call it a vacation or taking a tour
right why do people have to go into
exile usually we don't we don't
exile people very much these days
frequent punishment I suppose if you you
know we do it in a personal sense like
you really screw up your your personal
relationship and you find all your stuff
out on the porch you've been kind of
sentient to exile but we don't do it we
don't do it so much in terms of the
whole society like sometimes you know we
don't let people into places right you
can't eat here or you know can't shop at
my store but why would people get exiled
that could be part of it you get
somebody out of the way so they won't
get in trouble that wasn't usually the
case for these guys they they had it was
more active let's get them the hell out
of here threatened by their ideas yeah
that was that was a big part of it
there's actually what has come to be
called the stoic opposition and these
were people who followed stoic
philosophy who were critical of the
Roman Empire whether the Roman emperors
and some of the things that we're going
on in the court and they would say
things like you know you don't actually
have to obey the emperor it's your
choice whether you do that or not or
things were better back in the days of
the Republic or this is being mismanaged
or the emperor has the wrong priorities
and you know you you can understand that
that that wouldn't make them very
popular so Musso Gnaeus Rufus doesn't
have to go into exile but follows a
friend of his who actually is is exiled
by Nero rebellious flautas Seneca
himself and another important stoic
philosopher who had been advising Nero
he he attempts to retire twice I guess
you could say successful the second time
now how did you laugh but I said that
because there's a good reason
got murdered by Nero yeah well commanded
to kill himself I guess I guess you
could say that's that that's murdered I
mean we talked about Socrates being
executed by Athens right
if he hadn't killed himself then there
would have been greater penalties for
himself and his family
Seneca is trying to withdraw and
actually a lot of the writings that we
have like the letters that Seneca wrote
many of them are from that that short
period Seneca eventually oh good his
first exile yeah yeah well there's
there's that and then many of the
letters are actually from when he
manages to semi-retired you know so you
know I'm Sonia srew fost rebellious
flautists other other people this guy
have idiots Priscus who who Epictetus
talks about in his work these are all
stoic philosophers and they're all
getting themselves in trouble in one way
or another by practicing stoicism and
you know they weren't like we often talk
about speaking truth to power they
weren't like being social activists but
they would in fact some of them would in
fact say what you're doing the wrong
thing so if you want to call that
speaking truth to power but I guess I
guess it was and you know some of them
get executed and some of them get
banished boom Sonia's Rufus you know
goes in and out when things break down
under Nero there there's coos against
him right Nero eventually has to flee
Rome this guy fr adidas accompanies him
by this time Epictetus has been freed we
don't know when he actually started
teaching philosophy we know he was
studying philosophy and some people
think that maybe he started teaching
philosophy and in 68 that would have
made him probably 18 years old I find
that kind of hard to heart by that he
was he was doing it that that early but
in that year 68 Nero takes off if I
heard ITA's accompanies him and helps
Nero commits
then this guy Galba takes over and Galba
rules for a couple months and then we
have the year of the Four Emperors why
is it the year the Four Emperors because
Galba was number one and then there's
two other guys and then finally the the
space Ian takes over and then we've got
a stable government for a while but this
space Ian he doesn't really like the
philosophers and he banishes them from
Rome he makes an exception for a little
while from Estonia's Rufus because he
enjoys him but Epictetus has to get get
out of Rome
you know for a while and then with
sonia's Rufus eventually himself gets
banished Vidya is prettiest gets
banished and executed first he banishes
him and he says I'm taking that back
we're gonna kill you instead and we see
this this happened over and over again
there's a sort of a dynastic succession
after the spacey and dies Titus who you
may know from you know the wars that he
had out east particularly you know
against the Jewish revolts that were
going on at the time he succeeds him and
Titus doesn't really last that long
eventually he dies and his younger
brother DeMint Ian takes over and myth
Ian again banishes the philosophers from
Rome so this so that's a good question
so philosophers got kicked around quite
a bit in Rome and for different reasons
right by this time it's more yeah
they're a disruptive influence but
they're disruptive because they're
they're teaching things that call into
question state power you know and and
the way things are running and they're
you know this is a time of great chaos
they want to have an orderly succession
they want to have their they're trying
to manage this incredibly large
territory with all these different
people an economy that they barely
understand you know where inflation is
happening there's all these dislocations
and then you get these philosophers
coming in and and you know talking about
how people should change their their way
of looking at things
don't don't think so much about getting
money or you know prestige or preferment
was another term that comes up you know
being part of the Royal or we could say
monarch achill institution and
administration before that though there
was already a tradition of not wanting
the philosophers around and this goes
all the way back to the first
philosophers are coming from Greece from
Athens and actually they picked the
wrong philosophers in some respect for
introducing the Romans to philosophy
because there is this embassy and they
they have a stoic so the Stoics are
pretty straightforward you know they're
gonna this is what they believe they're
gonna teach you about that they often
get criticized for not engaging in
rhetoric very much for just presenting
their stuff in a very dry
straightforward way right but you know
what you're getting with a stoic and
then there's the Epicureans and they're
a little bit suspect because you know
they're all about pleasure turns out
that they are pretty ascetic you know
they're not about like just getting
drunk all the time and and having as
much sex as possible I think like that
they're about this very measured life
and enjoying enjoying pleasures but then
they had a skeptic an academic skeptic
philosopher and I think it was our
Castle aus I might be mistaken and the
first day he he presents a doctrine and
he's doing this to the Senate and then
the second day he argues against that
doctrine so the Romans are like what
which side does he accept and he's like
listen this is a skepticism we argue
both sides of the of the issue we don't
actually know anything you know but we
know that we can we can make good
arguments on
sites and some of the Romans are like
this is terrible this is just going to
if you let these people in they're gonna
tear a society apart because are gonna
teach everybody to argue both sides of
an issue and they're gonna undermine our
you know our cultural basis you could
say and so this guy Cato the Elder was
one of the people said these are these
people are bad news keep them out of
here
well the philosophers managed to get
into Rome the myth Ian managed once that
Dominion they actually managed to find
old laws on the books some to Airy laws
laws about what you could enjoy and he
managed to twist those in such a way as
to kick the philosophers out they were
some there because room had levee to a
fine yeah do you have reduced down to
like 50 talents was the reasoning like
the song like just go away it was like
reduce your pain like are they paying
intellectual protection let me I don't
think so
and you know when it comes to the Stoics
we know the the one who was involved was
the fourth skull our deities of Babylon
who was you know he was kind of you read
about him he was kind of fast and loose
guy when it came to FX he was not as
hardcore as like his successor who
criticized him on some things like I'll
give you an example so imagine that you
have a ship full of grain and you pull
into a port that famine has been going
on for a long time
you can charge as much as you want for
your grain right you can jack the price
up to the roof you happen to know that
there is an entire fleet of grain ships
coming in the next day behind you do you
have a requirement to tell the truth and
and you know let people know that the
price that you're charging really is
gouging or not dodge and he said no not
really
this is according to Cicero and then his
successor
auntie Potter said
that's a terrible thing to say you know
these things about his own teacher of
course you should tell them that there's
there's more grain coming in right so so
Dabney's we don't know you know we don't
know much about him unfortunately but he
probably was a good talker actually
anybody who became the head of a school
was probably a an excellent talker
Epictetus himself his uh his uh not
quite biographer but his chronicler
let's call him area and one of his
students said that he had a way of
speaking to people that would try to
like you know get them fired up to you
know change their life to do their best
it might not come through in the book I
kind of think it does but a lot of other
people find him quite dry so epictetus
he has to relocate he's got to get out
of Rome and so he goes to another place
that he's not from but is just as good
as any other place to be an accomplice
which is in Epirus which you know it's
part of the greek-speaking area and he
opens a school of philosophy and a
school of philosophy at that time as far
as we can tell you know it was sort of
like not quite a finishing school but it
was a school where you would send
younger men to get some culture and the
Stoics had a program of education it
included ethics which we know a lot
about from from the stoic writers but it
also included what they called physics
which would you know had to do with the
cosmos the universe but also a human
psychology so a theory of the emotions
theory about how our body works that all
was part of physics and then the other
thing that starts are really known for
is logic and when they say logic they
don't mean just symbolic formal logic
like we might have taken the classes and
they mean all the stuff that has to do
with argumentation and all the stuff
that has to do with how we know things
what we nowadays call epistemology would
follow or what they call logic and so
epictetus taught this stuff and and some
of it would be kind of rote
learning you know for his students and
then some of it would be putting them on
a spot and making them do exercises
there's actually a great story that he
tells when one of his students screws up
and you you know you could you could
think about this not just in terms of
students but think about like when when
you've got kids or employees and they do
something bad what do they typically say
that's not really a big deal why are you
getting so bent out of shape right and
Epictetus had a student said why are you
upset with me for screwing up syllogisms
it's not like I burned down the Capitol
and Epictetus says you know I said the
same thing to my teacher with Sonia's
Rufus back when I was doing this same
stuff and you know what he told me in
this this is burning down the Capitol
you know when you're doing an argument
if you get the argument wrong it's
completely wrong sort of like doing I'm
a math problem and so you can imagine
him you know being involved with these
young men and you know a lot of them
probably didn't stay that long
some of them he there's another great
chapter or one of them is considering
leaving because he's sick he says he
wants to go home and be sick at home
which meant it was like a boarding
school he'd go back to wherever he was
from and Epictetus says you can be just
as sick here as there and you can study
something and make something of yourself
and then you know he was also involved
with local people you know there's a
great story in there about there's a
local procurator who goes to the theatre
and everybody gets mad at him and they
get mad at him because they want to give
the prize to this comedian and he wants
to give it to somebody else and so they
start yelling and booing and shouting
and stuff like that and then he loses
his temper and starts shouting at that
and epictetus says what the hell's wrong
with you you know you're supposed to
provide a good example you're ticked off
at them for being ticked off at you when
you're though you're the only person in
charge there you know of course they're
not going to like you if you go against
their their wishes what did you expect
and so we see in this these interact
with some some are ordinary people some
are like people who are well-placed you
know and we get all of this because
there's this guy who studies with them
and they think it's around 108 AD or see
this guy Aryan who was a historian and a
military person and I should mention a
parallel here so everybody knows about
Socrates right
who is Socrates most important student
Plato we all know that or was it who was
another of his important students it was
a little bit more of a man of action
than Plato
no no Xenophon Xenophon was a historian
Xenophon was actually a military
commander he got stuck way behind enemy
lines there's a you know crazy story
that he wrote down about how he and
these other 10,000 Greek mercenaries
went to to do a job in Persia there was
like a fight going on you know in the
middle of the Persian Empire so they all
go over there and then they find out
that their employers died and so what
the hell do we do now well I guess we go
back to Greece so before they can
actually go back to Greece the Persians
invite them in the commanders for a nice
dinner and then they kill them all they
kill all the upper-level leaders so now
you've got these young guys like
Xenophon they're like wow what do we do
now they decided to march all the way
back to Greece taking Persian towns
along the way resupplying in those so
they they it was like sort of their
their coming-of-age story in a certain
way right and it was you know very
stirring there have been cool movies
made out of this well you know Xenophon
wrote about socrates - and we kind of
think that Xenophon is probably more
accurate that plate of a was right
there's this big problem with Plato
about did this idea really come from
Socrates or it did Plato just use
Socrates as his mouthpiece in some of
the cases
you know some of the later dialogues
it's probably not Socrates ideas at all
but Xenophon is a pretty faithful
chronicler you could say of his great
teacher
well Arian like many people in ancient
times you would look to a role model
Arian wanted to be Xenophon just like
everybody who is a military commander
back then who did they want to be they
want him to be Alexander the great
Julius Caesar wanted to be Alexander who
did Alexander want to be Achilles you
know everybody was looking up to
somebody and so Epictetus his students
wants to do for Epictetus what Xenophon
did for Socrates so he writes stuff down
he writes down these discourses
deitra moyen in in Greek which could
mean like wasting time you know just
sort of passing time dialogues but
they're really about who epictetus was
and what he taught it looks like we
probably don't have all of the books
unfortunately there's a theory that
there were eight books and we only
possess four now but you know in any
case Aryan wrote some stuff down now
epictetus doubtless said way way more
than what aryan recorded but it's a good
representative depiction now there's
there's one part of that that's not
strictly speaking true which is that
epictetus didn't write anything down he
did write things down for school Oh like
you know he when he's working with his
students he would write out what the
arguments were but that's just like
class notes exactly and and you know
we're kind of lucky that we have it
because if you think about ancient
literature we've lost most of it even
with thinkers like Plato or Aristotle we
know that there's there's works that
they wrote that we don't have like
Aristotle wrote he and his students
you know did surveys of something like a
hundred and forty three different cities
looking at their history their
constitutions we have exactly 100 the
constitution of athens it'd be cool they
have the other stuff you know seneca we
we probably have everything Seneca Road
I'm willing to bet but we we you know we
don't have that much from Epictetus and
it's only because he had this great
student that we actually know about the
guy he was very well regarded by people
in his town they thought he was you know
very honorable very moral they actually
at one point erected a statue to him
later on and we don't actually know if
this is historically true but reputedly
he was visited by one of the really good
emperors Hadrian Hadrian is is in this
this bunch the Romans actually only
talked about a few good at burgers
probably greatly so right mural wasn't
one of them even vez Bayesian wasn't one
Dominion he he we actually was kind of a
good micromanager and he tried to bring
everything you know into order but he
wasn't a good guy
Nerva and the dynasty that starts after
him Trajan Hadrian Antonius pious and
then Marcus Aurelius the the you know
stoic Emperor those are called the five
good emperors the only five good
emperors in history some people say that
the myth Ian was actually you know good
in certain ways but the rest of them
that mean Trajan was was considered so
good that the Christians considered him
to be a like a one of the virtuous
pagans in the Middle Ages so and Marcus
Aurelius you know we know about him in
large part because of his meditations
where he shows this great you know depth
and profundity and and moral commitment
we also know about him because of his
biography it was a great guy had
terrible son and
that was the end of the the great
Emperor's line but so Epictetus was
visited by Hadrian perhaps it's quite
plausible that while Hadrian was doing
this tour of the the East and Greece
that he actually stopped in and then
Epictetus you know not too long after
that dies and then you know sometime
after that Hadrian dies and that that
period really from from dimension being
assassinated and Nerva being taken
captive and then abdicating in favor of
Trajan that whole period is a time of
considerable I won't say peace because
they were fighting wars but good social
order you know Epictetus was kind of
fortunate he found a place to be he
could teach he could do the kind of work
that he wanted to do with with forming
young minds and characters and he just
stayed there he never married
he had a housekeeper apparently and
towards the end of his life he adopted a
child but he never that's kind of people
made fun of him actually for not
marrying because the stoic stress that
you probably should get married there is
this joke in Lucien of people saying
epic - you know epic you say everyone
should you know fulfil their role which
means getting married and then they'd
say will marry your daughter bring her
out
and then of course he didn't have a
daughter so but you know he lived a
really good life we don't really know
much more about his biography than that
but he fits within this time where
things are really you know in his early
years in great tumult and yeah banished
why don't they allow them to then start
schools Oh in other places they just
kicked them out of Rome because that was
the power sector oh they would then be
able to foment the masses
yeah so that's a good launching point I
mean the Stoics really were not they
were not rabble rousers you know they
they were if anything maybe too austere
to two moralistic for some of the
Emperor's like like Nero for example
right near I like to get away with doing
what near I wanted to do you can see
this poor guys salmon Seneca trying to
like steer him towards you know not
being a complete screw-up and slowly
losing control of that and I'm trying to
pull back and not being able to get away
from him
and some of these some of these other
Emperor's they're more interested in you
know you stoic should get out of our way
so we can rule and keep everything going
along in an orderly way don't be talking
about you know how the Old Republic was
good you know don't be on that that that
sort of thing
but if they want to go somewhere else
and then talk about the virtues and you
know how to fulfill your role that fits
in pretty good with with the Roman
Empire yeah so this is part of the
backstory the triumph the first
triumvirate right Julius Caesar Pompey
and Crassus the richest man in in Rome
they decided to share power they
actually offered a fourth person a
chance to come in on it and that was
Cicero and Cicero turned them down he
didn't want to be tied in with any of
them and then they could have offered it
to but they knew that he would never
agree to it they could have offered it
to one of the great stoic philosophers
and States people at the time Cato but
they knew that he would say forget it
because he was already opposed to them
and when it broke apart
Crassus dies and then Caesar and Pompey
are fighting with each other we usually
think about the civil war in those terms
people like Cicero and Cato were kind of
on the fence for a while and they were
on the fence in this way they definitely
were not going to be on on Caesars side
because he was a bad guy he was
power-hungry
he might even be an epic
Tirion there was some rumors about that
certainly wasn't you know somebody who'd
fit stoic philosophy sister was kind of
a stoic kind of not Cato's definitely a
stoic Pompeii is not a good guy either
he's really prestige driven he's kind of
a jerk you know it's kind of it's not
clear that he actually supports the
Republic but at least he gives lip
service to it so they they reluctantly
side with pay and we know who won it
wasn't Pompey plus a Caesar
and so Cato commit suicide and Cicero
doesn't but eventually he's going to be
killed by someone Cicero that they're
Caesars partisans under Mark Anthony a
bit later on so yeah there's this long
track record right that we can we can
talk about I have one question yeah
about your timeline here Seneca is a
peanut killed yeah that's a that's a
misprint should be Nero oh yeah Nero
Nero has when I was making this up I I
wrote the wrong thing in Nero had his
mother killed oh okay yeah and I mean I
don't think Seneca was really unhappy
about it but it was it was it was one of
the it was both one of the signs that
Nero was you might say slipping the
bridle so to speak and it was also
something that got somebody out of the
way who could have stood in his his way
so with the or how are we doing on time
with epictetus so stoic philosophy
rather let's talk about that very
briefly this I mentioned Stoics a lot
stoic philosophy was centered on a
couple key themes one is this idea that
that virtue is really the good and
everything else is is either bad like if
it's vice you know or if it's other
stuff it's kind of indifferent which
doesn't mean that we should ignore it
together but it just doesn't matter as
much as being just courageous wise
temperate or any of the things that fall
under that stoicism also really stressed
doing our duties fulfilling all of those
that kind of falls under justice it's
stressed living in accordance with
nature understanding nature as being a
fully developed human nature and you
know there were some other key points
that you could you could probably bring
up but I don't want to spend too much
time on that
Epictetus was in many respects an
orthodox stoic meaning that he's he's
following along the party line somebody
like Senecas considered a bit suspect by
some of the other Stokes and Epictetus
actually doesn't talk about him which
means that epictetus probably didn't
didn't think that Seneca was completely
a stoic at least that's what we think
but epictetus also made some really
interesting new twists and contributions
as well so is he Orthodox if he's
bringing in some new ideas or
consolidating the ideas that are there
in new ways that that's a question that
we can tweak Ananas right what are some
of the new things that he's bringing one
of the biggest is it's right there in
the very beginning both of the
discourses and what we call the
enchiridion which is sort of like a best
hits list of the discourses in the
handbook literally and Kater hand and
then the idiot means little so it was
like a little tiny book that you could
open up and read through it says that
there's some things in our control and
some things that aren't in our control
now you know Cicero says that to Seneca
says that - but they don't quite follow
it out the way that Epictetus does
what's in our control it's not the
external things so it's not our wealth
or our clothing or our social position
or even our bodies all right they're not
in our control and we can talk about
what that means you know wait a second I
can decide whether I you know take
medicine or workout or eat you know good
food or bad food yeah that's true but
you can still get hit by the bus and
minute you could be like that guy who
you know is the big jogging guru and be
in really great shape and then keeled
over from a heart attack suddenly you
you can control some of the things about
your body but you don't have total
control over right especially now in our
day of potential pandemics of antibiotic
resistant bacteria all right or things
mutated viruses so what's in your
control
well what you think and what you feel
and what you desire and what you choose
that stuff that's you know sort of a
small realm but that is in your control
and we might say wait a second I mean
what if you have a terrible day you know
that's not in your control if you feel
crappy afterwards and epictetus would
say well yes and no I mean the day might
be crappy but you choose how you respond
to it do you like fly off the handle and
start getting yelling at everybody and
you know or get really sad oh my life
sucks so bad you know or something like
that or do you approach it with a kind
of cheerfulness and equanimity that is
to some degree in your control and and
you can't like you know you think about
we talked about you know steering a ship
if it's a big ship you got to have some
time to turn it right and habits work
that way too so if you're habitually
let's say somebody's have bitterly
griping in the workplace about their
co-workers and they feel badly about
being passed over for promotions or
something like that if they're doing
that habitually they're not gonna snap
their fingers and suddenly change their
mindset and no longer think and feel
that way but you can you can work on it
that that is in your power and
eventually you can have a much happier
life and so this is something that he
stresses probably more than any of the
other Stoics I would say another thing
is Epictetus doesn't talk very much
about virtue instead he talks a lot more
about our social roles so like for
myself as an example
I am a teacher right I have about a
hundred and twenty odd students this
semester I have certain duties as a
teacher to them and they're not just the
things that are in my contract there's
certain like moral duties that I have
like you know it's a show up prepared to
class actually great people fairly you
know things like that that's part of
fulfilling my role I'm also a husband
and a father
I'm a citizen you know probably have a
whole bunch rules all of you have a lot
of rules right and if we fulfill those
roles the way we ought to even if other
people aren't doing it even if other
people aren't reciprocating us doing the
right thing by fulfilling our role we we
can decide whether we want to do that or
not it's up to us whether we're good
like epictetus says the universe doesn't
guarantee you have fought a good father
it just guarantees you a father you know
and you choose whether you're a good
child to your father even if your
father's a jerk that that's up to you
well the the in accordance with nature
business Epictetus brings in a new term
and its really interesting because this
is a term the only other philosopher in
the ancient world who uses the term
remotely close to this way is Aristotle
who's not a stomach he founded his own
school that term is pro racists which we
translate as Faculty of choice or
sometimes people translate it as will
it's the thing that does the choosing
for in you right and and it actually
directs itself so like when you say wow
I'm a screw-up I need to fix myself
that's the part of you that actually
chooses the fixing or if you say I need
to prioritize things the part of you
that does the prioritizing that's the
prior ASIS it's literally choosing one
thing in place of another grasping one
thing in place of another and Epictetus
says that's what you are at the core of
your being you're not your body you're
not clothing you're not all these other
things
you are the capacity to choose and that
is so powerful that it can choose itself
they can direct itself now if we're not
paying attention all sorts of other
things can direct us right so I gotta
think about the workplace where
everybody's whining and complaining and
if you let yourself get dragged down by
that you let yourself get dragged down
by that that's a choice but once you do
you're kind of you know going along with
it automatically and then you start
complaining and you know getting angry
with your co-workers or whatever is
correct but what's really cool about
this is you know this is a view of human
beings as autonomous is able to shape
ourselves to some degree to not just be
subject to whatever whims or desires we
have or instincts or external things
that tell us you know you have to do
things this way or fate or the gods or
anything like that
Epictetus is saying we actually have a
fundamental choice and so he calls that
praises he says we want to have that in
accordance with nature that's the thing
that we want to focus on and so you
don't for example to give a very
concrete case in the enchiridion he
talks about going to the baths now we
don't go to the baths right I mean maybe
you do but is there a bathhouse here in
Milwaukee I don't know maybe there is
the showers like any athletic club very
well except you don't yeah yeah you're
not you're not sitting in it so much so
think about the public swimming pool
right when you go to the public swimming
pool why don't people want to go to
public swimming pools other than the you
know the pee in the water right what are
one of the things that people complain
about oh it's so noisy you know those
kids with their radio or nowadays
everyone plays it on their phone
somebody might take my stuff you know
it's too there's too many people here
everyone's jostling each other so
epictetus says when you go to the baths
you have a choice you
think I want to go to the bath and I
want to have a good time and nobody
should get in my way and nobody should
steal my towel and you know what are all
the other things that could go wrong you
know nobody should should hit on me
nobody should you know knock my ice
cream over if I buy ice cream you can do
all those sorts of things that have
those expectations and you're setting
you're setting yourself up probably to
be disappointed or you can say I want to
keep my Faculty of choice my pro races
in accordance with nature and if that
means letting this other stuff go that's
what I have to do so then this is really
central what does it mean to keep it in
accordance with nature to not allow
yourself to get all upset about this
stuff to not allow it to be damaged give
you another example
Epictetus sinks like the other Stoics
that getting angry is not a good thing
for us he's got this great line where
he's trying to reason with somebody who
was getting angry with somebody else and
he says so let me get this straight they
did something wrong to you right they
harmed you in some way and Epictetus say
they didn't actually harm you you're
just deciding that they've harmed you
but let's say they did harm you so your
response to them doing something bad is
you're gonna do something bad to them
that you know is bad how the hell is
that gonna make you any better isn't
that just gonna damage you now I mean
they're already screwed up that's why
they're doing the stupid behavior that
they're doing you should actually
instead of getting angry at them
probably feel sorry for them but if you
want to get angry at them isn't that
totally irrational and if you allow
yourself to get angry that would be for
the Stoics we would say it's just
natural right the Stoics would say no
that's not human nature that's damaged
human nature totally realized human
nature wouldn't be getting angry on
people you would actually roll with
things you might actually laugh at
things you could probably look at the
people that are doing dumb stuff and you
know maybe damaging your your goods and
say you know those goods aren't me and
if that's the sort of thing that they
want to do I guess that's that's what
they're gonna do I don't have to get
emotional
invested in that all right that would be
keeping yourself in accordance with
nature for that big penis another key
idea that he brings up which has to have
come from other Stoics but we don't have
this in other stocks is what what are
called the three fields or the three
disciplines this has become a very big
part of modern stoic you could say
pedagogy and practice one discipline is
is what we call the discipline of desire
what is it that we we have to analyze
what is it that we desire what is it
that we reverse to do we have good
reasons for that are we are we desiring
the wrong thing should we redirect our
desire should we desire to have better
desires all of those could be a part of
that discipline and you can think about
what you know modern psychotherapy does
right looking large part figuring out
what do people actually want you know
sit down with a client they come in and
they're like I can't stand this person
and you're like well why not well
because they they rub me the wrong way
okay what didn't what didn't what they
do rubs you the wrong way and you talk
with them and then you find out that
they want people to treat them
differently yeah it's a desire right or
they're averse to I don't know people
talking to them in a certain tone so
that's an important part and then
there's the fat there's the discipline
of choice or action it's not enough to
know what you actually desired and start
reworking that and consider your
emotions you actually have to do things
you actually have to make choices you
actually have to do things that are
practical to change your life and you
got to do it over and over again and
then there's a third one called the
discipline of ascent and ascent yeah
like what you agree to or what you
believe and this is where like you know
the Stoics would be analyzing arguments
and thinking about well why do we buy
into this or why to be out by it to that
an epic foetus says the problem with so
many people and by the way Aristotle
says similar stuff the problem with so
many people when they're trying to
figure out what's wrong with their life
and how to make it better is they
constantly focus on the third
thing and they don't pay any attention
to the first in the second but really
you've got to work on the first and the
second in order for the third to pay off
Aristotle talks about it in terms of
like people studying ethics which has to
do with how to live a good life and then
they never actually practice any of it
it's sort of like today it would be
people who have like a stack of
self-help books but you ask him is that
a good book yeah I've read it like five
times has it worked out for you I don't
know I haven't actually tried anything
well what the hell are you doing with
the book that that would be like
focusing solely on this this third
discipline and and so epictetus you know
he constantly reminds people you have to
actually practice philosophy or you're
not gonna see any of the benefits from
it and you're probably not even going to
fully understand it so it's a very
different conception of philosophy than
what we preach in philosophy classes
today isn't it you know like an academic
philosophy classes where you know
ethicists quite often are not good
people we've had some major scandals in
recent years with like these big-name
ethicists who are sexually harassing
their graduate students for years and
years well that's a problem they're not
practicing what they preach the Stoics
were very big on I have to sing what you
preach and they gave a long list of what
they were preaching so there were a lot
of things to practice it might take an
entire lifetime now the one other thing
that I wanted to mention in terms of
history Epictetus had an effect on
history he influenced the last of the
great our good Roman emperors Marcus
Aurelius is a follower of epictetus you
know this is not the only person that he
follows but he cites him so here you
have an emperor who's citing a former
slave who he thinks is an important
philosopher that's around epictetus as
time
there are other so he was alive no yeah
but it's it's it's you know it's within
the same century after Epictetus is
death yeah after Antonius Pius so they
could have their lifetimes overlap at
all that's a good question I mean if
they didn't there's not a huge guy well
you know Epictetus ism
so this these discourses right and the
enchiridion they were floating around
out there in the form of Scrolls that
you could read and so Marcus would have
would have read Epictetus he read a lot
of other people to his sites you know
they'll for asked us who we don't we've
got almost nothing left at his stuff
unfortunately he was an Aristotelian
thinker and a whole bunch of others as
well yeah about 130 nobody's really
quite sure
Martha okay so they did over that but
they're in different places and yeah
yeah he went he would never have
encountered him but yeah it's kind of
kind of a cool thing to think about so
Epictetus his works were preserved at
least part of them
the enchiridion got commented on by this
guy simply kiyose in the sixth century
AD simply kia seems to missed out on
some of the things that that big penis
is saying like he didn't catch how
important prior asus was there's some
other things about that as well but but
simply kiyose wasn't a stoic simplicious
was a neoplatonist
so he's not from the same school so he's
got different ideas the the monks you
know in the Middle Ages at least in the
West the main book reproduction was
happening
monks were copying things although
actually it wasn't just monks nuns did
too and we know we found some really
interesting things about manuscript
illumination looks like nuns were
involved with that I don't know if you
any of you see that recent thing about
the that one who had the lapis lazuli in
her teeth yeah from you know probably
licking her brush she was a manuscript
illuminator so clearly women were
involved in some of this textual
production stuff but here's the thing
with with the monks they they they kept
seneca they turned seneca into kind of a
pagan saint there was actually a fake
correspondence between seneca and st.
paul floating around for a long time and
so they're like yeah seneca and st. paul
they were they were on the same page
Epictetus they turned into a Christian
as well and it's interesting because
epictetus probably knew a little bit
about the Christians he calls them the
Galileans and he just passes over them
very quickly he thinks they're nuts
you know just like so many other other
people that he runs across and then he
doesn't say anything about them the
enchiridion talks about the
Philosopher's the monks turned that into
the monk they also added lines here and
there into it and effectively
Christianized epic Tina's turning him
into a more palatable person so stoic
philosophy continued under that guys his
discourses were also floating around we
know that for example the boldly in
library had a 12th century manuscript
that others were copied from so in
medieval Europe they did have some
epictetus although he wasn't being read
quite as often and then you know by the
Renaissance one of the things that made
the Renaissance the Renaissance was
republishing all these these manuscripts
these renaissance humanist authors would
go to the monasteries where quite often
the monks didn't really care that much
about the books in their life
very you know they would copy them out
they sometimes didn't even know what
kind of bug is that sometimes didn't
know you know what they had in their
libraries and these guys would go in and
poke around and then they would come
back and they would say okay well this
is this needs to be republished and
let's take the manuscripts and come up
with what we call a critical edition
where we look for all the different
manuscripts and where they coincide and
where they differ from each other and
figure out which one is probably right
which one is wrong well doing that put
Epictetus you know much more back in the
the forefront it also brought you know
Seneca into the forefront and also
Marcus Aurelius stoicism became a big
thing again
through the Renaissance in the early
modern period so you have these
Christians who are looking at Epictetus
and the other Stoics as being more or
less on the same page as Christians and
trying to bring together Christian
thought and stoic thought and you know
sometimes they were you know pretty
successful with this sometimes other
Christians thought that what they were
doing was actually really off-base
Pascual for example criticizes Epictetus
and he thinks that the reason why a
patinas is wrong is that he is too
optimistic about human beings
the Stoics stress the the grandeur of
human nature they also stress how
screwed up we are but they think that we
can all fix ourselves whereas you know
Pascal thinks that's a little
presumptuous you probably need some
divine grace to do that you need some
some help along the way some people can
fix themselves but if they can it's
probably because God helped them to be
in a state where they they you know
they're not as screwed up as everybody
else and so there's a lot of thinkers
who are bringing up epic epictetus
throughout the ages particularly in the
early modern period kind of falls out
you know he does get read but he can
falls out of favor I would say then
until the 20th century and then there's
a couple other things that really put
Epictetus back on the map one of them is
the cognitive revolution in
psychotherapy Albert Ellis was a big fan
of that patinas because Epictetus would
say things like it's not the it's not
the person saying something that insults
you it's your judgment that you've been
insulted that is causing you to feel
insulted and so Alice you know drew upon
this and then the whole you know
cognitive family coming after him ever
kind of indebted to Epictetus as well as
I guess you could say to Seneca and the
other Stoics another person who's quite
important in the story is James
Stockdale do you guys remember him he
was Ross Perot's running mate he totally
lost the debate that he was involved in
although a 2% of the people polled
thought that he won the debate believe
it or not it was a three sided debate
who was where are the other principals
in that one that was when Perot was was
the the spoiler between Bush and Clinton
right so it was Bush it was Quayle and
then Al Gore so we were Gore Stockdale
and Quayle and I mean he made Quayle
look good so that's quite an achievement
but he wasn't very good on stage he was
however very good in his writings
Stockdale had been a prisoner of war in
Vietnam and he survived the camps and he
attributed surviving the camps to having
read and thought about and applied
Epictetus the reason that he did that
you know it was kind of hero worship on
his part it's kind of funny we come full
circle Frederick the Great
you know the Prussian King who fought
against like everybody all at the same
time for about seven years and it's
called the Seven Years War and then
basically bankrupt this country doings
Oh
but he's our great general he used to
carry Epictetus as I'm karidian around
in his coat pocket and so
stockdale thought that was really cool
and he started doing that and started
reading it and then when he got shot
down and got put into those camps and
those cells and you know they were
trying to use him for propaganda
purposes he had something he could draw
upon he realized that epictetus could
provide you with a way of living and
thinking that could help you survive
horrible situations kind of an
interesting insight isn't it and the
only thing you control your mind yeah
any reactions like do these modern
sources do they address that because yes
counterpoint yes and and so there's
there's a willingness to say that with
certain kinds of compulsions or mental
illnesses maybe those are out of your
control but you you know let's say you
find out that you your brain chemistry's
off it's up to you whether you take your
medicine or not right there is still
some realm that is up to you how what
you make of your your condition whether
you go to support groups or not that's
that's that's still to some degree up to
you there's a there's a yeah there's a
much greater recognition that it's not
like well everything is totally up to me
but even up athena's didn't think so he
thought that habits very hard to break
he talks about anger for example once
again he says if you allow yourself to
give in to anger you've already got this
scar tissue that you've built up now
it's like whipping that and breaking it
up and and you know coming up with even
worse scar tissue afterwards and that's
gonna make it harder for you to resist
it the next time around so there's an
understanding of
we have to use white Christianity aligns
whoa they like this dog well yes and no
I mean some Christians hate Stoics wait
and one of the things that it boils down
to is I guess where you fit in on the
idea of how much you need grace right in
order to to fix yourself I mean are you
fixing yourself or is God fixing here
right I think a lot of Christians are
kind of kind of uncomfortable with the
idea that it's it really is up to you
they call that pelagianism you know
after the after the monk Pelagius who
taught that you know you yet everybody
had enough grace to like fix themselves
augustine attacks him in the West yeah
so I mean it's it is something that
people take into account we can we can
talk about other things like if you're
growing up in a war zone you know or if
you're growing up in generational
poverty it's really gonna be a hell of a
lot harder you can't just like bootstrap
yourself out of it right and modern
stocks are attune to that and one of the
things that the Stoics are good about
stressing at least some of them there's
a lot of people out there once stoicism
became popular a lot of people got on
the bandwagon and are trying to use it
to make money or to justify whatever it
is that they want to do but Stoics are
really supposed to be about justice
that's one of the virtues and justice
involves a not just you know sort of
following the rules and the laws but
benevolence towards others and trying to
fix social situations that are that are
really screwed up there wasn't a hell of
a lot of room for that at the Roman
Empire other than like somebody giving
you power and when stomachs
got power they usually curbed the
corruption and you know set things right
when they could and that's often how
they got themselves in trouble alright
so I mean modern Stoics if they're
really Stoics and they see people in
intergenerational poverty they
want to do something about that they and
part of the reason why they would want
to do something about that isn't just
because it's unfair for those people it
would be a way to try to make it
possible for them to live a better life
by changing who they are you know by
transforming themselves it's not good
it's not good to be an intergenerational
poverty in part because there's so many
influences that are that are hitting you
that make it hard for you to become
independence and see things you know in
a less sort of reactive way right and
the Stoics would want that for them so
yeah it's funny favorites waves yeah
well so epictetus talks about what is
what is genuine freedom and slavery
right
Epictetus says that if you desire things
that other people control you're a slave
even if you're the Emperor somebody else
has got their hooks in you you know or
as we say they can push your buttons
right if you you know if you have like a
chip on your shoulder and anybody can
take you off like some of these people
on websites right where you just got to
say the wrong thing they're they're
super angry at you
typing in all caps they're kind of
slaves that's a crappy way to live in it
and you could be a slave and yet have a
much greater degree of real freedom and
so this is actually good I didn't get to
talking about this
there was a prevalent view of stoicism
for a long time as being a reaction to a
world in which everybody was basically
in one sense or in other slaves all the
way going all the way up to the Emperor
so that you know people withdrew from
the world because they felt like they
didn't have any control into a sphere
that they could control and and that you
know made them feel better that was a
very common view in the
19th century and I think it went on into
the 20th century and they they sort of
is tied in with a history of philosophy
the real philosophers were Plato and
Aristotle who had this whole you know
metaphysical depth and breadth and they
were in the time of the Greek
city-states when individual citizens
could still decide things and then you
know Alexander the Great comes well
Philip of Macedon comes through and then
Alexander with a much larger Empire and
then you don't really have any freedom
you can't participate in a political way
you're just part of some vaster things
so so you withdrawn to your own private
life as a stoic or an epicurean or a
skeptic or something like that and many
important philosophers put out that line
Hegel would be you know a good example
of that many of the historians of
philosophy of the 19th century had that
that sort of viewpoint on things and I
think now there's a recognition that
that was that was a mistaken view of
that really what attracted people to
stoicism was not just that it left them
like withdraw from life and not be
bothered by things they saw it as almost
like a what some people call the
technology of the south you know it
allows you to to figure out how you work
and then tinker with it in ways that you
would actually have more control more
direction you would you would get to
decide what to do with yourself and
you'd be able to orient yourself to
their good and you would be able to live
in this whole matrix of relationships
with people who matter to you that's you
know that's a pretty good thing
stoic stressed this need to fulfill your
social duties sitting or something Oh
such a strain and I will sound like a
radiator right yeah so I mean that's
pretty much all I have to say about this
guy Epictetus hopefully it's been quite
rambling but hopefully all the prior
races he
ro h AI r e sis p ro h a i our the s is
and it comes from the words that mean
the pro right and in front of our in
place of and then hide rain is to grasp
to grab on to and so your your you know
you can actually translate it as like
prioritizing you know I want this rather
than this because I can't have both
thank you yeah and and it's a very
useful concept you could translate it as
will if you want to you know in our in
our contemporary sense of the term we
think and you know you think about our
pry raices can be in better shape or
kind of damaged
you know we choose what we feed it
that's not what a patina says but it's
not a bad metaphor I think so what you
guys had some questions for me already
what other questions or comments or
things you want to bring out so you know
Foucault uses that this is this guy
Michele Foucault who is a French
philosopher and historian and it's not a
bad way to talk about it makes a lot of
sense
you know you treat yourself as if you
are if you think about what technology
is it's something that's that's
penetrable to are tinkering around with
it we can come up with an idea of how
things work and then we can swap out
components or you know turn dials or
things like that obviously we can't do
that with our psychological you know
matrix quite so much it's not leaking
like i'm gonna take out the the part of
me who's a jerk and swap in a better
better component right but you can you
can work on yourself so it's kind of a
good metaphor i think would you
equivalent to spiritual practices yes
and you know hadou and Foucault are
connected with each other that's right
isn't yep well influence yeah yeah and
and I mean it's not a radically new idea
I mean the Stoics just aren't calling it
technology they're they're talking about
it in terms of like using your rational
faculty to to rightly judge appearances
including those that constitute your
rational faculty or things like that
right but it's the same basic idea
people are kind of getting at that with
the notion although it's a bit more
superficial of lifehacks right you hack
yourself you hack the life that you live
meaning that you you break into it and
then you you change the programming so
it suits you better the life hack thing
does have that sense of like why I can
just like change this one little thing
here and this one little thing here and
this one little thing here and then
everything else come on great rather
than looking at it as a whole connected
system but you know I mean that's that's
an issue for any sort of intentional way
of living whether it's stoic or
Aristotelian or Christian or Buddhist or
pick whatever you want every time you
start looking at yourself through the
lenses of these things you have this
experience after a while of saying oh
man things are much worse than I
realized this is why you can have like a
little off topic but you can have Saints
like Saint Anselm in his prayers and st.
Anselm was a good guy saying I am such a
miserable sinner I'm so far from God you
know and you're like well Jesus if he's
that bad what what about me
you know but you know for an some the
closer that you got to the divine or the
transcendent or whatever like for the
Stoics what what truly realized human
nature would be the more aware you are
of the flaws that are still within you
the more you see just how much work you
have to do at first you're like that's
not that far from here to there and then
you get like this far
you're like man it's a lot farther than
I thought paradoxically because it kind
of recedes right because you know
yourself better and you understand human
beings better and you understand how the
world can easily you know lead us down
paths that are good for us and I think
that's that's something that you see in
all sorts of intentional ways of living
you know yeah you hear the phrase
happiness is a choice I mean would you
say yeah this is the origins of
something like that it could be an
origin I mean I mentioned Aristotle
right so Aristotle thinks that there's a
number of different sort of viewpoints
on what happiness is out there and some
of them are wrong and people believe
them and then they script their life
because they believe them like for
example thinking that making a ton of
money translates into happiness some
people actually believe that in ancient
times and some people believed that in
the present and you look at people who
are making a ton of money and they're
often not very happy you know if they
are it's not because of the money it's
because of other things and another one
Aristotle considers is like pleasure
he says it's it's good to have pleasure
it's it's fun you know I was actually
talking with my class about this today
you know what what do they like to do on
vacation they're very prudish it's it's
kind of funny the this current
generation you know we have what are
physical pleasures well drinking eating
nice food sleeping in you know watching
Netflix none of them want to say having
sex you know
although the ancients you know they knew
that that that was something that we
desired and I told all my students man
if we didn't have desires for that none
of you would exist right so but you know
that a life devoted to that it's not
it's not a terrible life but it's not a
completely human life the Aristotle says
that's a life that's kind of fit for for
pigs actually epictetus says people who
are like that they're like sheep he uses
the metaphor sheep just want to screw
and eat all the time you know and that's
good enough for them but we need more
and so Aristotle talks about choosing
something more than that he he equates
with virtue and having relationships and
having some wealth right so maybe it
fits here the silver stories kind of
thought yeah you could be happy by
pursuing virtue that was just weren't
you yeah and I read recently I don't
know anything about it happen Aristotle
had a different view there were some
things that the Stoics we call preferred
indifferent exactly yeah yeah he thought
that you need to have some small measure
of possessions and and wealth and you
also need people to share it with and
that was it he you know he it's nice if
you have health but you can be happy
without health although if you have
really terrible health Ariston let's say
you're probably miserable you know but
for him it was about virtuous activity
as the main thing you just need these
adjuncts for the Stoics you know they're
more radical they're like you could be
happy just with virtue the perfect yeah
yeah but you know you notice he doesn't
say he doesn't say I wasn't I was happy
okay right
he just wasn't as miserable as all the
other guys but did you mentioned yes
Albert Ellis yeah his thing is this
psychology rational emotive
psychologists I can't yeah yeah and so
to go back is happiness a choice the
Stoics Aristotle they would say yeah it
is it is a choice but it means you have
to choose the right things so it's not
just like I you know I'm unhappy and
somebody gives me a greeting card that
says happiness is a choice I'm like oh
you're right I'm gonna choose to be
happy right I got actually like do
things that will
will allow me to feel happy which
probably means like figuring out what
the hell is wrong with me what and why
I'm miserable and and I think that's
where a lot of people get stalked right
because they're like I I don't like
being miserable and then they you know
they could help the self-help book and
the self-help book says well you need to
do this and this and this and they're
like that's really good yeah it's a
great idea I'll do that tomorrow and you
know in a way it's kind of funny too
because if you think about diets right a
lot of them are pretty much BS like
you're just gonna eat potatoes and and
and limes for a month right so you know
the lime so you don't get scurvy well
it's a terrible diet right but if you do
it you'll probably lose weight you know
pretty much if you do anything and you
pay attention to what you're eating and
you restrict the amount that you're
going to lose weight you're probably
going to gain it back right as soon as
the diet's over and with like spiritual
practices you could probably pick almost
anything and if you actually did it for
a month straight you probably would be
marginally happier you would be less
screwed up right now that doesn't mean
that it's actually gonna stick that
needs to be part of like a comprehensive
program that you're committed to and and
and probably you probably do need to
share it with a community I think this
is one of the things we're modern
stoicism so go back to your question
about like the recognition about human
nature
the Stoics talking about is being social
creatures and there's probably a better
recognition now that we don't have to be
these like you know heroic individuals
off by ourselves
totally you know impervious to fate but
that's better than we're actually like
connected with each other and support
each other
that loneliness is a bigger killer yeah
reporting some more than cancer
cigarettes it's they're finding out that
it has actual physiological effects on
us which makes sense you know it's funny
there's all these things where
scientists are like that's all bs those
those crazy medievals or ancients they
believe like people could die of a
broken heart you know and then they
start studying and they're like well
actually you can damage your heart by
living the wrong way you know and and
having all this this sadness or anger
ever totally off topic here Aristotle
thought that anger was a boiling of
blood around the heart
and he actually thought that the brain
didn't do the thinking for us the heart
did the thinking and that the brain was
sort of like a radiator you know it
keeps the blood cool you know he didn't
actually have a notion of a radiator of
course cuz they didn't have cars back
then but yeah I mean we're finding out
that that if you get angry all the time
now it's that because BOTS blood is
boiling around your heart but it does
screw up your heart or it screws up
other things for you you know it could
be all the cortisol streaming through
your systems right yeah
but the ancients weren't totally off
about a lot of this stuff you know
between the body and the mind that's a
good example we're you know we did we
had to put down one of our dogs who was
14 years old and he was really you know
he made it to the end and he was body
was failing and he was having seizures
and stuff like that and we put him down
because he was really no longer himself
for more than just a little bit he
snapped at my wife and almost better
than the person who raised him from a
puppy and then he like caught himself
and he was like he had almost like a
hokey look of horror on his face and we
have another dog who's 13 years old who
grew up with him she got very depressed
you know that my wife was very concerned
that amiko will go
within a few months of Magnus dying now
she's bouncing back but it took a lot
you know she didn't want to eat you know
she's droopy she kind of sign
now she's now she's more or less back to
normal she she likes to eat a lot and
play and stuff like that but you know
when she dies what's gonna happen to the
cat who's 16 years old she might go
right away you know well yeah but then
that then we have to start the whole
thing all over again
but this this idea about like needing
people I think there's really something
to that and I think a modern stoicism
should be more forgiving about that I
know what do you mean you guys are part
of the stock fellowship what are you
guys thinking about stoicism for quite a
while what are you guys thinking that
about that proposal yeah and not just
community but we need closeness we need
we need affection we need connection
with other people that maybe the ancient
Stoics were a bit - yeah a bit too
focused on like you know I can be
totally good by myself I mean I should
still be able to be good by myself if I
have to be but maybe I can't fully
realize what it is to be a human being
on my own the ancient Stokes would say
you could you can you could be the
hermit outta the woods you know I I
wrote a short treatise a year ago Tom
that I was trying to work with the idea
of expression of this idea even used the
idea of a spouse is dying and oh okay
and
the whole idea of being attached to
whatever you think that you are and so
it's yeah the lines of like your job and
so you could attach to your job and say
you're in architecture so yeah don't
think of yourself as mark to think of
yourself as a builder and so you know
maybe early in life you actually
physically build them okay design
and then on when you can't do that
anymore than you teach and so you're
always teaching building yeah but
something that you can control and not
something that is external to you and so
that I extend that to the idea of a
spouse where you know if you think of
yourself as I am like my definition as a
person is the spouse of this person yeah
then once that person is gone then your
definition is gone
you don't have control over that
definition yeah I always been taken from
yeah I mean that's actually a great
yeah try to find on instead of calling
yourself a spouse either like say you're
here giver and so now now you're or a
partner yeah yeah but and so and then
you know you can transfer this thing
into on to someone else or you know
you've got grandchildren we're just you
know people that need help that I think
is actually a really great idea and it
could work within relationships to and
you think about like when people go
through midlife crises it's often very
hard on their spouse because the spouse
is like hey I'm not having a midlife
crisis what the hell's wrong with you
you're not why do you want to do all
this this this stuff that you didn't do
before
maybe redefining what one's role is
because you know why do people go
through midlife crises sometimes it's
due to job issues or top job
dislocations actually Randy you'd be a
good person to you know ask why do
people go through midlife crises what's
what is your experience not as if that
as somebody who had one but rather son
who's been a therapist
I in some ways this particular angle on
it I had frankly thought about yeah you
know there's certain things that I take
for granted my own life I guess I should
well it's natural that we do yeah yeah
and I've thought of Stoicism as more
part of the ethical yeah Nicole
sort of approach an approach to ethics
and also kind of way of feeling you know
this is what the purpose of life is yeah
and but part of it you know roles they
certainly talk about roles which one
role is that your role is in
relationship to other people it's
important for stoicism but I for anyway
it's my wave thing you've been serving I
mean do you think that you think that a
lot of couples wind up in trouble
because they understand their roles as
you know it comprises this this and this
early on and then you know the situation
out there in changes and maybe one of
them gets that the role actually
includes something else or something has
to drop out but the other one doesn't
and then you know like the thing about
like sex for example or or money matters
you know a lot of people get into
relationships and they don't they don't
really want to think about money but if
you're going to live with somebody for a
long time you actually have to be honest
well hey
really his study couples a lot this guy
John got it oh yes yeah yeah yeah it's
about there's two kinds of problems are
solvable yeah and one of the keys to
having a relationship work is to be able
to manage unsolvable problems because
you can't solve yeah by other people
they're not gonna be mirror images of
you yeah they're gonna go in a different
way at some point and you're gonna go in
this way and how do you how do you work
those things out yeah the big problems
like buying a house you can solve those
but you know I want to be more
independent she wants to be more
together
those are always there yeah I don't know
if that's family issues I like that too
like well you know these are your
in-laws yeah they're not so yeah you
know the one thing that I really liked
about Gottman's oh you're welcome
the thing I really like about his book
was that point that he made about you
can tell who's who's likely to make it
by if they show contempt for it yes if
you show contempt forget it the
relationship was probably doomed yeah
that's that's one thing that he says he
can tell within half an hour who's gonna
get divorced or maybe even laughs yeah
the contempt is that killer and I I was
into this at one point I don't remember
the other kinds of things that you can
work with but contempt is really yeah
you know Aristotle talks about like the
difference between anger and hatred
anger somebody does something that you
perceive as bad you want to punish them
right but you still want to maintain a
relationship you want them there so you
can punch them or you know say something
mean to them that's why I like when they
start walking away like hey don't walk
away from me I still have more to say
you know hate Aristotle says wants the
other person not to exist literally not
to be like maybe even not even be in the
past if possible and and so heat is much
more dangerous than
anger because you know you can't really
do much with it if somebody doesn't want
you to exist and think about what
contempt is you know you're just scum
you know what can you do with that you
know I mean from a stoic perspective as
well I don't control their feelings but
you know I here's a good question for
those of you that are you know sort of
arguably modern Stoics should we stay in
relationships where somebody is
radically contemptuous towards us or
should we say that's a sign I shouldn't
be in this relationship
you know I mean I think some of the
old-school Stoics when I said well you
put up with it sort of like Socrates put
up with xanthate bay you know she was
real mean but you know Socrates was good
about it Epictetus says stuff like that
I don't know about that kind of
masochist well a masochist would do it
because they get some yeah some kicks
out of it in some way with Epictetus it
wouldn't be I get pleasure out it would
just be like well this this doesn't have
to affect me so I'm not gonna let it
affect me but that's that's one where I
you know I'm a really hard time with you
know where let's party he is importantly
kind of back to this thing about how
optimistic yeah major I mean what good
are you doing not only for yourself but
for this other person if they're really
contemptuous of you yeah who are you
helping by are you helping you're not
helping yourself probably are you is
there something you're doing for a while
why continue this if it's yeah
beneficial either person I mean you
could say like if you have kids or
something maybe maybe this is where
people are well it's better to be out of
the relationship and you know sharing
time you know with the kids that
maintain a really terrible toxic
marriage because you know in some ways
you're not you're not just putting that
that model of contempt in front of the
kids all the time
look I think that's arguable yeah yeah
sighs just the relationship is
you ask the relationship with the
children that's another but if it's just
you I mean the traditional stomach thing
gonna be well it doesn't really matter I
mean you can be happy anywhere including
a crappy relationship you know I think I
just don't think that that you know so
again yeah the human nature thing
maybe if we our stomachs ages we could
be happy anywhere right
but the stomachs say this age only comes
around every 500 years so if if we want
to be realistic about ourselves we have
to recognize that we can't put up with
everybody's [ __ ] for forever right
and contempt and yeah do they want to
let you go that's true you end up being
the spouse that's been killed yeah yes
normal is it or will they also or will
they also do like a scorched earth thing
we're gonna be burden the finances yeah
I mean it's it's interesting this is a
tangent when I first went on Facebook in
2009 I was astounded to find out how
many of the people in my high school
class because first you like find all
your classmates back then on Facebook
how many of them were either recently
divorced or their marriages were in the
process of breaking up you know there
was around 40 years old
and it was really every was before like
all the financial crisis stuff and put
major stress on marriages you know and
no actually no I'm wrong 2009 there was
the financial crisis maybe that played
an important role but it seemed like it
was it was the time for people to say
screw this you know and the irony we all
went to Catholic Memorial so presumably
some of them still thought divorce was a
bad thing but they all you know we're
perfectly fine with that was it because
they they you know wised up and said
this is not gonna work
was it because they were incapable of
sustaining a lasting relationship
probably that you know mix of different
motives but yeah this is kind of a dark
tangent joy so I guess as someone that
fairly recently just ended a
relationship
one of my major reasoning that's I
didn't see my partner wanting to improve
herself ah and you did yeah and she was
was working at a job that she just
despised and and she had some history
background that results in that she was
credibly cautious hmm with all things
okay and is this well now this is
getting to the point where you're like
having to ask these questions like is
this a life that I want to live and
especially because yeah all the
conversations usually results in her
ever around how she hated her job yeah
I'm like I don't want to live the this
if you don't want to try to do something
to make your experience better yeah I
mean there's the two things there one is
if you think about like when we're
spending time with each other it's the
same thing like in a friendship your
friend is constantly bitching about
stuff you got to wonder well what are we
what are we actually doing here what's
what's the what are the goods that we're
attaining in our social interaction
you know our partnership I mean some
people really do just like to [ __ ]
together you know but but I think most
of us aren't like that and then there's
the question of well do I do I stay in
this because I should be helping them in
some way you know and there's probably a
risk for Stoics to become you know the
proverbial white knights the people who
are always saying well if I just extend
them a little bit more open the door for
them you know leave leave stoic quotes
laying around yeah supervisor we don't
listen to our taken we'd go over the
tapes of this session so yeah and this
guy was just insufferable that the it
was he was actually a patient okay yeah
and I'm thinking and you know who's
great he was telling me his life was
gradually improving but I thought like
what's you know my supervisor one yeah
and so I kind of you know broke this up
with my SID when I listen to other
people react to this when you go on and
on like this the answer was or nobody
listens but you that's a good one
well sounds like they're kicking us out
oh well on that note let's end and
thanks for a great conversation
you